what do you think about this this
approach in terms of data sets of using
data from the internet do you think the
internet has enough structured data to
teach AI about human civilization
yeah so I think the internet has a huge
amount of data I'm not sure if it's a
complete enough set I don't know that uh
text is enough for having a sufficiently
powerful AGI as an outcome
um of course there is audio and video
and images and all that kind of stuff
yeah so text by itself I'm a little bit
suspicious about there's a ton of things
we don't put in text in writing just
because they're obvious to us about how
the world works and the physics of it
and that Things fall we don't put that
stuff in text because why would you we
share that understanding
and so Texas communication medium
between humans and it's not a
all-encompassing medium of knowledge
about the world but as you pointed out
we do have video and we have images and
we have audio and so I think that that
definitely helps a lot but we haven't
trained models uh sufficiently uh across
both across all those modalities yet so
I think that's what a lot of people are
interested in but I wonder what that
shared understanding of like well we
might call Common Sense
has to be learned
inferred in order to complete the
sentence correctly so maybe the fact
that it's implied on the internet the
model is going to have to learn that not
by reading about it by inferring it in
the representation so like common sense
just like we I don't think we learn
common sense like nobody says
tells us explicitly we just figure it
all out by interacting with the world
right so here's a model of reading about
the way people interact with the world
it might have to infer that I wonder
yeah uh you you briefly worked on a
project called world of bits training in
our RL system to take actions on the
internet
versus just consuming the internet like
we talked about do you think there's a
future for that kind of system
interacting with the internet to help
the learning yes I think that's probably
the uh the final frontier for a lot of
these models because
um so as you mentioned I was at open AI
I was working on this project called the
bits and basically it was the idea of
giving neural networks access to a
keyboard and a mouse and the idea could
possibly go wrong so basically you you
perceive the input of the screen pixels
and basically the state of the computer
is sort of visualized for human
consumption in images of the web browser
and stuff like that and then you give
the neural or the ability to press
keyboards and use the mouse and we're
trying to get it to for example complete
bookings and you know interact with user
interfaces and um what did you learn
from that experience like what was some
fun stuff this is super cool idea yeah I
mean it's like
uh yeah I mean the the step between
Observer to actor yeah is a super
fascinating step yeah well the universal
interface in the digital realm I would
say and there's a universal interface in
like the Physical Realm which in my mind
is a humanoid form factor kind of thing
we can later talk about Optimus and so
on but I feel like there's a
they're kind of like a similar
philosophy in some way where the human
the world the physical world is designed
for the human form and the digital world
is designed for the human form of seeing
the screen and using keyword keyboard
and mouse and so as the internal
Universal interface that can basically
command the digital infrastructure we've
built up for ourselves and so it feels
like a very powerful interface to to
command and to build on top of now to
your question as to like what I learned
from that it's interesting because the
world of bits was basically uh too early
I think an openai at the time
this is around 2015 or so and the
Zeitgeist at that time was very
different in AI from the Zeitgeist today
at the time everyone was super excited
about reinforcement learning from
scratch this is the time of the Atari
paper where neural networks were playing
Atari games and beating humans in some
cases uh alphago and so on so everyone's
very excited about training neural
networks from scratch using
reinforcement learning
um directly
it turns out that reinforcement learning
is extremely inefficient way of training
neural networks because you're taking
all these actions and all these
observations and you get some sparse
rewards once in a while so you do all
this stuff based on all these inputs and
once in a while you're like told you did
a good thing you did a bad thing and
it's just an extremely hard problem you
can't learn from that you can burn
forest and you can sort of Brute Force
through it and we saw that I think with
uh you know with uh go and DOTA and so
on and it does work but it's extremely
inefficient uh and not how you want to
approach problems uh practically
speaking and so that's the approach that
at the time we also took to World of
bits we would uh have an agent
initialize randomly so with keyboard
mash and mouse mash and try to make a
booking and it's just like revealed the
insanity of that approach very quickly
where you have to stumble by the correct
booking in order to get a reward of you
did it correctly and you're never going
to stumble by it by chance at random
so even with a simple web interface
there's too many options there's just
too many options uh and uh it's two
sparse of a reward signal and you're
starting from scratch at the time and so
you don't know how to read you don't
understand pictures images buttons you
don't understand what it means to like
make a booking but now what's happened
is uh it is time to revisit that and
open AI is interested in this uh
companies like Adept are interested in
this and so on and uh the idea is coming
back because the interface is very
powerful but now you're not training an
agent from scratch you are taking the
GPT as an initialization so GPT is
pre-trained on all of text and it
understands what's a booking it
understands what's a submit it
understands um quite a bit more and so
it already has those representations
they are very powerful and that makes
all the training significantly more
efficient and makes the problem
tractable should the interaction be with
like the way humans see it with the
buttons and the language or it should be
with the HTML JavaScript and this and
the CSS what's what do you think is the
better so today all this interest is
mostly on the level of HTML CSS and so
on that's done because of computational
constraints but I think ultimately
everything is designed for human visual
consumption and so at the end of the day
there's all the additional information
is in the layout of the web page and
what's next to you and what's a red
background and all this kind of stuff
and what it looks like visually so I
think that's the final frontier as we
are taking in pixels and we're giving
out keyboard mouse commands but I think
it's impractical still today